but i want to get a little perspective
on only fans i think that only fans gets
kind of a bad name
all right and maybe we can kind of set
the record right
um
rousson kind of said thirst trap times
capitalism
and you're like no that's that's exactly
what it is so here's the lovely ali ray
um by the way put everybody's youtubes
and descriptions in
uh the commentary below in the
description below uh but this was the
cnn interviewed you i believe correct
so set the tone here well let me set
this up so this former icu nurse makes
200 grand a month
from
only fans all right this was i think at
the time last october when only fans was
august yeah last august contemplating
reversing their decision on
more risque content
thanks to i don't know freedom of speech
first amendment i don't know what it was
they reversed their decision probably
more money more thirst trapping as
ruslan likes to say but apparently you
went from
again being an icu nurse during covet
arguably the hardest job on the planet
at that point
to being one of the
more disrespected jobs on the planet i
would have to say
uh so we'll get into that apparently
because you know we talk money on here
you were going from making about 84
grand a year to making six figures a
month
very quickly too yeah it was um it was
it's been crazy it's been life-changing
yeah we're going to get into that so
let's talk about that what made you say
all right i'm done with the nurse thing
i've been doing it for x amount of years
time to go full time with the only fans
let's walk us through that
well i i have to stop that first because
i i didn't choose to leave nursing
realistically on my own i was kind of
pushed out
i was discovered by some nurses at the
hospital who
found out that i was on instagram they
found out that i had an only fans and
brought that to our management's
attention and once they found out about
it it was just meetings back and forth i
was devastated um so they snitched on
you absolutely um so you know how they
say you know
snitches get stitches but you're in the
hospital right so i mean
it was really bad um to go from
one of the most respected nurses on the
unit i was very senior i was getting my
doctorate i was just about to graduate
um to do research for neonatal um ice
you know for care and it would just
i went into a meeting and they slid
across the table pictures of me that
they should not have had with sharpied
out parts
and said you know this has become a
distraction on the unit and if you
continue you have to leave and it that's
at that point
i obviously made the decision to leave
after many months but it was so toxic of
an environment just like so emotional
all the time i hated it i was like why
are these people out to get me so bad um
and so then i did choose to leave at
that point but it was an ultimatum it
was i really it probably wasn't legal
what they did looking back um but i
didn't ever what was the ultimatum
exactly delete it or leave and i delete
the only fans yeah and i felt like you
know what even if i delete this right
now this is not going to change what
these people think about me now they
don't you know it's already a
distraction so i at that point
i mean i was making so much money still
working full-time as a nurse i mean a
lot of money um and
i never i don't i would have left
nursing but i don't think i would have
did it then and i don't like the way i
was put out but yeah that's how it all
went down so would you have still
stayed a nurse and on only fence one
hundred percent i mean even though
you're printing money and only friends
you would still got up done the whole
time i did with the code you would have
done it i was making probably like 75
000 a month still working full time as a
nurse like no joke and i didn't even
phase me like i just went up and got to
work it was like i had all this money
rolling in elsewhere but it never felt
permanent it always felt like
i don't know this is going to stick
around and i just i like i said i just
got my doctorate i was actually going to
university of western australia to do i
had a full ride and everything to do
research for neonates and that that was
what my immediate plan which was a part
of the reason why i didn't mind leaving
um the hospital because i was like well
i'm going to australia i'm about to use
my doctorate now and
we didn't end up doing that things
changed very quickly very quick let me
ask you a question then i want to get
everyone's perspective on this by the
way natalia do you have that video that
francisca sent you
check on slack for that we'll pull that
up when you're ready but um
you why did you even start only fans if
you said you liked your job you were
making money you're happy you've been
doing nursing for how long nine years so
nine years so almost a decade what's
what made you say you know and you're
married i met your husband
you must have had a conversation before
you started only fans i assume
and he said honey go for it right i mean
walk us through that
i think a lot of people think it's just
me it's actually my husband and i's only
fan so it's he's not the innocent one
there but um what started so you guys do
it together yes all of our contents
together and it's sexual content
together
fully 100 going at it yeah boom
so this is
walk us through that conversation
who started it well okay so who said hey
there's a thing called only choose who
was the first person
honestly i think it was during
everything was the lockdowns okay and i
had i had an instagram with about 3 000
followers i would do beer reviews i love
craft beer and people used to always say
you guys got to start an early image you
got to start online and we used to
ignore it we ignored it for years and
then that story came out about belle
thorne making a million bucks in six
hours and i was like
oh that's the site they're talking about
well we didn't even realize what it was
and when we went on there and started
kind of
you know toying around with it and
signing up i posted a couple pictures of
us and
within i mean it was like that it money
just poured in and so then it became
very hard to turn a blind eye to it and
so
you kind of evolve and you know what
people are asking or and honestly the
way that our content is people look at
it as like porn or this or that whatever
sorry but whatever it is it it's
literally just like we're just doing
what we normally do and what everyone
else is doing we literally just put a
camera in the room like nothing else is
scripted or changed it's just a camera
in the corner how long have you been
married uh 20 years so if you like that
clip click right here to watch another
or if you want to watch the entire sauce
cast click right here
[Music]